Now Sarah has shown you another example of a interface, and I hope you've
become more familiar with how they work. They're really pretty natural. But
when you think about it, there is something mysterious going on. In our
suburban scene, we had an array list of drawables. Houses, cars, dogs and so
on. We got one of them, store it in a variable of type drawable, of course,
then call the draw method on it. That has
[UNKNOWN]
d belongs to the drawable type, and drawable has the draw method. What's d?
It's the variable, so it holds a reference to an object. An object of what
class? You might think it's an object of class drawable. Now wait a minute,
there is no class drawable. Drawable is an interface. So that can't be it, and
in fact, there is no way of knowing to which class this object belongs. There
is only one thing that we know about it, this object belongs to some class that
has a draw method. And in fact as you loop over the various elements in the
array list, this line of code may call different methods. The draw method of
the house class, the dog class, or of some other class, so far unimagined, that
also chooses to implement the drawable interface. This variation is called
polymorphism, which is just a fancy word for saying different shapes. In our
scene, that's a very appropriate name. Because the draw method can draw
entirely different shapes depending on what the implementing class does. But
the term polymorphism is used generally in Java to indicate any situation where
you have a method call and the actual method called depends on the type of the
object. Now, why is polymorphism important? It let's us build expandable
systems, where we can add new types without having to change the essential
logic of the program. I'd like you to try this out and add a new type to our
suburban scene. Namely a ball class and simply the kind of ball you may find
lying on the street. And when you do that, note how little of the program you
have to change.